Here's another example.
You have an image and
you want your network to say
it's an image with a cat in it.
it doesn't really matter where the cat
is, it's still an image with a cat.
If your network has to learn about
kittens in the left corner and
about kittens in the right corner,
independently, that's a lot
of work that it has to do.
How about you telling it instead,
explicitly, that objects and images
are largely the same whether they're on
the left or on the right of the picture.
That's what's called
translation invariance,.
Different positions, same kitten.
Yet another example.
Imagine you have a long text
that talks about kittens.
Does the meaning of kitten
change depending on whether
it's in the first sentence or
in the second one?
Mostly not.
So if you're trying to network on text,
maybe you want the part of
the network that learns what
a kitten is to be reused
every time you see the word kitten,
and not have to relearn it every time.
The way you achieve this in your own
networks is using what is called
weight sharing.
When you know that two inputs can
contain the same kind of information,
then you share the weights and train
the weights jointly for those inputs.
it is a very important idea.
Statistical invariants, things that
don't change on average across time or
space, are everywhere.
For images,
the idea of weight sharing will get
us to study convolutional networks.
For text and sequences in general,
it will lead us to embeddings and
recurrent neural networks.